this movie has a very solid lesson in it
and it is this if you're going crazy
don't take pills otherwise you're gonna
go crazy yeah that's how I see it it
makes sense to me side effects so side
effects is directed by Steven Soderbergh
he's done great things before he's done
ok things before and the two main stars
in the movie are Rooney Mara and Jude
Law Jude lies Rudy Mara's psychiatrist
who's going through depression so he
gives her pills and gives her a bunch of
different kinds of pills then the pills
have side effects so now it's a whole
lawsuit thing and I'm watching the movie
going
yeah but why does it exist Rooney Mara
is very good in the movie Jude Law is
very good in the movie Channing Tatum is
in the movie he's not bad in the movie
but it's almost like Channing Tatum's in
the movie because Soderbergh was like I
liked you in Magic Mike being my movie
for a little bit his role could have
been played by anybody's what I'm saying
long story short this movie the first
half of it is boring as [ __ ] that's what
I'm saying it interested me because the
subject of depression is interesting to
me personally but as a movie I was like
this is dragging on dude but halfway
through the movie you finally realize
what the movie is and then it becomes
good and the movie is a mystery like how
I said it like that all awesome I was
gonna say it like Bane there's some
mystery cuz it's more fun and you just
you really do believe that it's a
mystery that way talk to that you're
like oh look at that that's the point
awesome so now I can put the key in the
lock and now we have something here
before that clicks in your brain you're
just kind of lost and as a mystery the
movies really good you got the court
case going on and Jude Law scrambling to
save his ass and this person has their
side of it that person as their side of
it you're like who's bullshitting who's
very cool on the edge of your seat can I
[ __ ] well on the edge of your seat in
the sense that not really edge of your
seat you're sitting back going I'm
processing this information but my brain
is on the edge of its seat which is the
front of my skull brains can be on the
edge of their seat - oh and it is
relevant stuff do you ever see the
commercials on pills and they're like
side effects include all this stuff
that's worse than what you're going
through Catherine zeta-jones is in the
movie again is funny because I gave her
[ __ ] in broken city I was like she's
looking her age now nope in side-effects
she's looking young again apparently
she's The Curious Case of the reverse
aging hot chick that are you know
photoshopping After Effects and all
those things they do with movies
probably the second one so side effects
has really good acting a really
interesting premise a really real
event premise swear on this movies you
like the more you think about it when
you first watch the movie or like I
don't know where this is going and this
is boring as hell halfway through the
movie or like okay we're getting
somewhere by the end of the movie you're
like okay that was interesting the next
day you're like that was good doesn't
change the fact that for the first half
of this movie you are left in the dark
going why am I being bored right now I
will say side effects is a very good
time no alcohol required but a very
specific genre you're okay with slow
mystery type movies then you'll like it
you'll like it a lot but I will say when
the movies done you think back you're
like why did that happen if that you
know you start piecing it together and
you start finding flaws but it's still a
good thinker and I enjoyed the movie for
what it was so what's your favorite
mystery out there it doesn't even have
to be a movie movie game book whatever
Reichenbach Fall the season finale of
Sherlock season 2 on the BBC I took it
which means you can't oh I guess you can
you do have that freedom whatever your
favorite mystery is comment below let me
know and as always if you like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more
[Music]